automobiles ligier albon moteur cette
fois c'est fait l'année prochaine les
ligier ont obtenu que la régie renault
continue de leur fournir des moteurs de
formule 1 si donc il y aura une équipe
française très compétitive malgré le
retrait de l'équipe renault c'est
l'aboutissement d'un long feuilleton
j'en anr ligier ces dernières années a
toujours connu des problèmes dans sa
préparation
après avoir utilisé le moteur matra puis
le moteur cosworth ligier a bien du mal
il ya deux ans obtenir un moteur turbo
in extremis en 83 la régie renault
accepte de l'équipe est nouvelle
campagne dès le dernier grand prix
d'australie la reconduction du contrat
avec les moteurs renault est signé mais
les conditions changent le gouvernement
médiateur par l'intermédiaire du
ministère des sports apporte dans
l'escarcelle de ligier un milliard de
centimes
argent pris dans la caisse du fonds
national pour le développement du sport
autre soutien pour ligier huiliers elle
jadis soutien de l'ex écurie renault
health ou dont on ne connaît pas la
participation exacte a choisi ce nouvel
associé au total cette vente de moteurs
s'élève à 3 milliards de centimes soit
le double de la somme demandée aux
écuries anglaises lotus et tyrell pour
la même prestation
mais les anglais et notamment lotus
n'apprécie pas du tout cette nouvelle
ouverture commerciale de renault
il menace même d'utiliser l'an prochain
le moteur allemand bmw seulement en
attendant s'il veut encore avoir deux
pilotes sur le même podium la saison
prochaine ligier devra peut être revoir
son problème de climatiques toujours mal
placé dans les qualifications
ce serait pour l'écurie française une
grosse amélioration je me sens moins
seul pour l'instant